how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today we have some really interesting
and really exciting news from the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
and Kevin Feige has recently dropped
sort of a bomb about Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness and how it's
going to introduce new characters into
the movie and into the MCU these are new
characters he said that we've never seen
and he also said that we probably
wouldn't guess would be in this movie or
be introduced in the MCU at this time so
it's really exciting and we'll break it
down but first only one day left in my
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway be sure to
subscribe but notifications turned on
and click the link in the description
down below to enter so here's the clip
of what Kevin Feige had to say about
introducing these new characters into
the MCU in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness Doctor Strange the
next Doctor Strange film for instance
features some new MCU characters that
will be making their debut in that movie
that you won't expect or won't guess who
it is
but we found a cool way to make it work
because we needed a particular we will
want to make a particular type of movie
there and there was a character we
always wanted to do something with who
we think will fit really well there so
as you just heard there's not going to
be just one new character coming in
multiverse of madness but there's going
to be several characters it didn't say a
new MCU character he said new MCU
characters and then he goes on to say
that with these new characters making
their MCU debut we probably won't expect
who they are and probably won't guess
who they are but of course we're going
to try and guess who they are but what's
interesting is that he says that Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness is
going to be a very particular movie they
wanted to make a particular movie and
with this movie comes one specific
character that they had in mind that
they've always wanted to do something
with but hasn't fit any movie until now
well what do we know about this movie
the one thing that was mentioned before
about Doctor Strange in the multiverse
of madness is that it's going to be a
horror type of movie and in the same
interview Kevin Feige commented on this
as well
multiverse of madness is the greatest
title we've ever come up with by the way
which is one thing that's exciting about
it and I wouldn't necessarily say that's
a horror film but it is it's got there
and our director has pitched it it is
it'll be a big MCU film with scary
sequences in it but that's fun it's fun
to be scared in that way and not a not a
you know horrific torturous way but in a
way that is legitimately scary cuz Scott
Derrickson is quite good at that but
scary in the service of an exhilarating
emotion so Scott Derrickson the director
is calling it a horror movie and Kevin
Feige does say that it's going to be
scary but not in the torturous way so
what character is going to be making
their MCU debut in Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness well it kind of
sounds like this could be mephesto
recently there has been a lot of rumors
that mephesto could be making his MCU
debut I even did a video recently on how
he could enter the MCU in the Wanda
vision series and I'll link that up
above but it actually makes sense for
him to debut in multiverse of madness
his character can be scary he's
essentially the devil he can literally
trap people in Hell which honestly
sounds like they could make that'd be
pretty terrifying in a movie and like
Kevin Feige said it's a character that
they've always wanted to do something
with well if you read the Infinity
Gauntlet comics which infinity war and
in game were based off of Bethesda was
by Thanos his side pretty much the whole
entire time he served
Thanos but his true intentions were to
steal the Infinity Gauntlet from him it
would have been great for him to make
his MCU debut an infinity war or endgame
but it didn't really fit with the story
that they gave Thanos and the MCU but
now since Marvel is going to tackle
their first scary movie that involves
magic and the mystic arts mephesto is
kind of a perfect candidate now of
course everybody is expecting nightmare
to be the villain of multiverse of
madness but Kevin Feige said it's
somebody who we wouldn't expect for
guess and people have already been
guessing that nightmare is going to show
up in multiverse of madness in fact the
director and the writer have already
said that in Doctor Strange 2 they want
to do nightmare so if he's referring to
somebody we wouldn't expect or guess
it's not nightmare so it seems like
there's a good chance that it could be
mephesto making his MCU debut and Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness but
let me know what you think about this
who do you think it could possibly be
let me know if you think it is in the
comments down below also don't forget to
like this video and
subscribe but with notifications turned
on so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win Xbox one or a PlayStation
4 again only one day left and the
Infinity Gauntlet giveaway be sure to
click the link in the description down
below so you can enter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof